une question que j'adore pourquoi dit-on
copains comme cochons être copains comme
cochons c'est être comme cul et chemise
ou comme les doigts de la main bref
inséparables mais le plus étonnant dans
cette expression c'est qu'elle n'a rien
à voir à l'origine avec l'animal le
copain c'est celui avec qui on partage
son pain le bon compagnon en somme le
cochon de l'expression lui vient d'un
mot d'ancien français soso celui-ci
venue du latin socius signifiait
compagnon l'associé sauf que ce sont
c'est pas facile à dire le mois donc
progressivement évolué en sochaux puis
cochons au xvième siècle on disait déjà
camarades comme cochons au 18e amis
comme cochons et enfin copains comme
cochons qui sonne encore mieux aucun
problème donc à ce que nous soyons vous
et moi copains comme cochons